what would be the next uh destination
Adventure destination with camels or you
we go get Africa I gotta go back just
different parts that was actually 2023
yeah
yeah why just because they called you
the n-word with the heart off oh I did
get called the n-word with the hard r
with the hard R in a good way
yeah
and watch the whole thing happened
somehow that should be offensive to
everyone and even Al is like
are you sure because he was well he's
like
French Montana I was like you gave the
pass to French Montana or he has passed
so yeah I mean I'm in Africa so you're
getting called it by by Africans so like
even like I could just tell it was like
endearing but it was just it was hard
hard
how he was supposed to say it you know I
mean yeah yeah it was weird but yeah I
really want to go back to Africa that
was my goal for 2023 and then this
happened overnight so that was cool yeah
knocked it out early yeah we gotta do
more adventures and then we ended in the
pool bro that was the best part oh yeah
yeah hanging out in the pool just
singing singing vibing yeah we had a
great [ __ ] time
to me no no I just might have a problem
that you'd understand
we all need somebody to
lean on sometimes your Moroccan
sometimes you Mariah can't subscribe
Alex if you could help me dishonest
I have to put the thing on I want to put
the content on let me put the Capstone
oh my God
foreign
no we gotta do more Adventures we are
gonna do more Adventures I really like
this I hope you guys like this I hope
you enjoy and if there are any like the
you know very cool unique experiences
that we can tap into please let us know
I mean an underdog in the semi-finals of
the World Cup a team that should not be
there at all to go to like the Homeland
and watch it with the fans that have
been like rooting for them might never
happen to decades it might never happen
again yeah so it's like well it it
definitely won't happen again that the
first African team to navigate to the
same finals I guess we're there for a
[ __ ] first so yeah so we want to know
about all these other little things and
then just go out there and and explore
them man and with more time I think we
could do more like flagrant meetups
because we get to Marrakesh and then all
of a sudden he's like great Moroccans
where like Casablanca or like let me
take you out let me do this yeah yeah
hip-hop artists all this for Morocco so
I think with some more prep time it can
be uh yeah and the more unique the
better I feel like there's mad people
listen they're like oh my culture is
like too weird too Fringe like we like
that no one knows about us what's the
festival that happens in your town no
one knows your city we want to go food
has to be good though we like good food
yeah you you do I like good food it has
to be fine it was mid
night say it say it and you're single
right now it was mid Moroccans hit them
right now it was mid the food was good
food was good I went with incredibly low
expectations because when I went with my
wife the poo is not good so it exceeded
my low expectations
the last thing is Moroccan home before a
Moroccan restaurant that's facts okay
no we're a good restaurant we had good
food it was good good it wasn't great
yeah it's not you don't go to Africa for
that my New Yorker standard would you
have gone back to any of these
restaurants yeah if I was in America I
wouldn't go I wouldn't go and be like oh
yeah if they were in New York I'd
probably go but I'm not I would yeah
and you gotta is the best food in the
world that's the problem so when we go
other places is they gotta Light It Up
expectations gotta light it up we can
recognize it's still great though no
they got lighted up giving Grace and
light it up I don't like anything that's
not New York I realize this and it's
yeah you're lucky they let you in a
Manhattan
the next World Cup is in North America
are you guys excited about that yeah yes
so the next World Cup is in North
America that means Mexico America and
Canada and Canada
but
but we have to pick and choose the
destinations to watch the games Mexico
City
got to have to I mean we got a few games
here in New York yeah New York too got
to pull it up New York Mexico City we
gotta pick our spots yeah
New York Mexico they're probably gonna
do one in Miami do they know the exact
locations yep Miami's not a city you
visit no that's not that's not the one
that's not it that's not the one I don't
remember places 2026 host cities okay
Atlanta Atlanta Boston mid Boston he
missed Dallas that's what's up Atlanta
all right
Houston probably fire Houston's honestly
Kansas City let's go Los Angeles okay
Miami hell yeah New York absolutely
absolutely Philadelphia Miss San
Francisco Miss yuck Mexico where do we
got Mexico City estadio Azteca we're
[ __ ] doing I know the craziest one
bro Monterey oh Monterey oh my God
that's that's happening that up with
this we're crazy that's happening
oh my God that's happening that's
beautiful oh my Lord we gotta catch that
game let's catch both yeah mofa yeah but
Mexico's a spot if you want to be
Toronto I'm cool probably fun for
tomorrow good yeah but before that I
mean look we also have it on Paris
Olympics in two years that's true
culture though for culture yeah yeah
it's it's different
we're going to Mexico for soccer are you
kidding me so my question is who
qualifies because normally it's a host
country qualifier I think all three all
three thanks wow and I'm pretty sure
they're expanding the World Cup to more
teams but that also makes sense too
because you want to engage North America
as much as you possible yeah so I mean
Mexico is obviously going to qualify
Canada so we automatically qualify the
host country code qualifies yeah Qatar
was in the World Cup obviously yeah yeah
I mean they beat a team I know they lost
right the first game how the [ __ ] Saudi
Arabia was in the World Cup did they
qualify yeah oh they were actually these
yeah the one team that beat Argentina
because they qualify within their yeah
and then America qualifies through
concacaf yeah all I'm saying is listen
if you trying to gamble on the World Cup
you're trying to gamble on Sports you
trying to put that money on American
football you know using betonline.ag
promo code flagrant matching 50 of that
initial deposit bonus up to a thousand
dollars you already know what [ __ ]
time it is so if you put money up you
parlaying that [ __ ] you're doing with
betonline.ag supporting this podcast
supporting yourself that's free money to
gamble with even more money to make you
are absolutely welcome We're Coming For
That World Cup I'm very excited yo I'm
excited that even at 39 years old I've
just
I'm excited I found soccer
true it's this absolutely amazing sport
you're born again soccer I'm a
born-again soccer fan like as silly as
it sounds I'm genuine I'm genuine about
it like how cool to be excited about a
new thing at this age it was so
anxiety-inducing though yeah I think
it's not best for you yeah having a
rooting interest in soccer you're just
constantly worried constantly worse
[Music]
I just think it's complete [ __ ] I
think what you mean in three weeks
you're not gonna get Pokemon soccer
I think you won't care about it until
the next world comes yeah yeah yeah
right now I like I like World Cup soccer
for example hold on hold on hold on hold
on I'm gonna like when is the concaf cup
or whatever
that [ __ ] if you're doing that okay
because the europas I'll probably get
into a little bit that's in two years
our [ __ ] I'll get into a little bit Copa
America Copa America I'm gonna get into
but I'm being honestly
you're lying it's hard for me to get
into the team you lived in Barcelona you
could be you could be a Barca fan he
lived in barthol and I didn't give a
[ __ ] there yeah that's a good point and
they won La Liga how bro I used to see
them [ __ ] at the club you live
there one of the greatest Styles in
Barcelona history I've met all them
[ __ ] at the club soft not
enough soft low man now Ronaldinho was
that dude right these hair never been
dry yeah wow [ __ ] bro never been
dry yeah he's crazy and he's probably
partying mad mad [ __ ] one of
the most recognizable human beings on
the planet got caught with a fake
passport in I'm pretty sure Uruguay he's
one of the most famous [ __ ] on
the planet and distinct looking yeah
ain't that many people look like him bro
all right he out here bro he outside he
went to prison I like after he retired
he went to like it was like like a nice
person for like a year or something like
eight months but why why do you have the
fake ID yeah I don't know why bro I'm
not literally done these [ __ ]
are crazy bro how are you gonna change
your name if you're Ronaldinho hey bro
it's nuts but all I'm saying is I'm I
like soccer and I enjoy it so I'm I'm in
I'm in yeah I think you're gonna pick a
team in I don't know if I want to do the
team people should Lobby people should
Lobby you they should be like yo support
this team okay everyone get their sales
pitcher man you fan if you're a real
Madrid fan Juventus fan give me the
story like I need to know the Baxter I
like I know the backstory of like
countries that's what's exciting to
support them but as far as like a
regular team goes what's the geopolitics
of man united that's what you need to
know yeah I need to get into that yeah
give me the story The Hotspurs the Jews
like them yeah an answer fan yeah I
don't know I gotta figure it out that's
your team right that's what I'm saying
so I can't even no you could beat him no
but you're doing it the American way of
like going after the players yeah I'm
trying to find the club that I support
say again I'm American yeah
right yeah I guess no that's not that's
how black Americans pick teams oh shut
up it's true y'all just pick the most
famous player and then you're a fan of
that team that's not true most famous
black guy the most famous black guy yeah
they go on the team no yes we yeah let's
see LeBron on I like that too that's why
I don't like hockey yet that's why as
soon as there's a big famous face
you like someone in NASCAR Formula One
uh the I love Brandon guy
okay guys listen we gotta wrap this up
thank you all so much uh for [ __ ]
with us make sure y'all [ __ ] with Jager
thank you for doing this thank you for
pushing everyone out of their comfort
zone this is going to happen without you
just being like yo we're [ __ ] doing
it respect respect thank you guys for
coming on the journey yeah yeah let's do
crazy things thank you for never
planning anything and being always last
minute all the time yo it's so much more
exciting it really is we got to get I
gotta frame that text that text embodies
this podcast yeah bring a passport and a
change of underwear I'm not sure if
we're going yet yeah that's just great
right yeah let's live life like that
okay guys uh to Adventure thank you so
much Jaeger thank you so much you guys
for being down to do these things Akash
I don't know how many of these
Adventures you're going to want to do
but uh you're a great sport I'm a good
sport you're an unbelievable sport I'll
give you that you didn't complain not
one [ __ ] time I stayed out as late as
everybody else you stayed out as late as
everybody else no no like
mainly because I didn't know how to get
home yeah I was there though he was
there never complained not one time
that's big so we're gonna have to figure
out these Adventures
barakas what do you think what do you
think the goal is for you yeah let's go
to India obviously yeah I think you get
tired of that [ __ ] too yeah I kind of
feel I feel like we'd be out there
raging and you'd be like oh I wouldn't
party in India no right be very happy
outside yeah but when y'all go to the
club I'll be like I'm [ __ ] tuckered
out bro here boy he's trying to get out
of going out so bad what'd he say he
goes oh I'm gonna wear sweatpants to a
club multiple times Club bro how are you
gonna wear sweatpants to a club you know
they got a dress code and then no he
knew it because as we were walking up he
goes I'm probably not gonna let me in
you know
why do you think that why do you think
because in true Akash fashion I tried to
pee at a casino earlier and they
wouldn't let me know because I had to
pee I found out I couldn't get in oh
that you can't even pee here no they
wouldn't even they were like dude no
there's a guy wearing a dress you're
looking at you he's in a dress no teeth
oh you can't be here look at you in your
Nike Tech disgusting oh my God
all right guys we're gonna figure it out
we're gonna figure it out going out you
know going out singing all that [ __ ]
that was fun yo dancing with dudes fun
yeah so much fun I love that you did
like that that was fun
adventure yeah we do for you I'm telling
you India let's go World Cup of cricket
let's go next year that's an activity
yeah you know what you would get into it
the same way you got into soccer
for that event you would get into it I
promise you you would yeah I promise you
you would I probably would
I promise you you would let's do this
all right we'll get a sweet or something
so we have to like you know [ __ ] in the
you get like a toilet but we're gonna go
I would love to go to uh what's the the
holy or whatever oh yeah yeah is it
Diwali or holy holy holy is with the
color color I would love to do that I
mean that would be funny magic couldn't
do that no [ __ ] with the real [ __ ]
this guy he could have gone to a bar and
watch the game here there's Moroccan
restaurants we got to get some Adventure
into you come on dude we gotta get some
Adventure in you part of it is going
there and experiencing the enthusiasm of
the people and getting caught up in
I
know what you mean
but I don't believe it what do you not
believe I just don't buy it and see what
you're selling you know how it you know
how your dad is like I wish I believed
in God I wish I believed what you were
saying like I'm with it right but I
don't I don't it sounds good it sounds
good yeah I wish I had this right here
you believe it yeah but but here here I
don't yeah but but God you can't see
and another country you can like see it
you can experience it you can feel it
like what do you get from going I'm down
to go to the other countries but when
y'all are like hey let's go out I'm like
let's go in
I saw the country now I got to see the
club club is a club as a club
it's different Doug I mean it was
completely different like seeing that
band do that was amazing no that I've
never seen that in America that I was
into yeah but then the second night we
both bailed
on whatever we're gonna whatever Duff
was getting into Shenanigans yeah he was
chasing [ __ ]
I mean no
I know
okay yeah yeah that made you look
weirder to me yeah no I didn't I didn't
I went above his butt
um but we're going to get you into
Adventure I look forward to what about
like nature Adventures is that something
that you would do why green ribbon what
if I got offended by that question
because I really I want us I've told you
as this I want us to I want us to white
water raft in the Colorado River in the
Grand Canyon I want us to and then camp
on the sides the greatest thing ever
yeah amazing what is that even yeah what
is that even I'll get outside your
comfort zone that's not my comfort zone
I've never camped before first time I'm
gonna do it is after going white water
rafting in the Grand Canyon the Colorado
River that's amazing you lay there and
you look at the stars and go bro we're
just a little ball flowing through the
universe oh I saw shooting stars out
there that's right yeah that was dope no
meteor shower a meteor shower whatever
same thing
wake me up for it uh I did I sent the
text on a group that's true no yeah we
wake up it's waking up that's true but
yeah I think that we need to get into
these Avengers get outside of our
comfort zone I think that's a smart
healthy thing to do bro
white water rafting awesome I've done
that right it's fire right and then you
camp after I know I was trying to be
awesome bro that's human I didn't know
it all white people but it was fun well
I gotta defy death
this is what your ancestors
but it's like his life what is what is
like a fun thing for you what like how
do you have fun yo I'm down to travel
I'm down to sightsee I'm down for all
that I love going to Morocco yeah yeah
yeah I just you know all the going out
part ended up being fun but initially I
was like I'm gonna go but this [ __ ] is
gonna be [ __ ] what are we gonna do I
can't you know how I know I'm old when
music is loud I get upset because I'm
like I can't even hear myself think
I mean I get it he's been consistent I
gotta yell the time
hey Amelia I love it you're a great
sport I will say that you're an
absolutely great sport let's go see the
sights doing the activity camping like
tents or glamping tents bro I think it's
I think it's actually like
no tense I think you're just craziness I
do believe it's very crazy [ __ ] party
no not in the Grand Canyon you're inside
this guy's a crazy [ __ ] person it's
gonna be 30 degrees animals I get a
little like Critters yeah Little
Critters dogs yeah scorpions yeah why
why are we gonna I'm telling you open
ourselves up to scorpions while we sleep
I don't know but that [ __ ] I don't know
I have to look into it more yeah but
also there's nothing for you to do so
once it's dark you just go to sleep and
it can be dark at [ __ ] 6 30 or some
[ __ ] like that then you're gonna wake up
with the sun it's just yeah imagine you
find [ __ ] to do yeah talk story you'll
be safe you'll be safe wake up sit
around a fire listen to [ __ ] huberman
over here waking up with the sun yes bro
yeah